all right Josh is in Seattle hey Josh
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey let's pay to talk to you thank you
for taking my call
sure man what's up so my wife and I have
just read your book full money makeover
we're very excited we're working through
the steps one step two and so we sat
down we have five kids the oldest is
nine young mrs. one we sat down and
talked to them about Christmas and said
okay we're working on a budget now this
Christmas may not be as extravagant as
we've had in years past what do you make
music I make about $70,000 what did you
spend on Christmas last year about a
thousand dollars and what were you
thinking of spending this year
considerably less what were you thinking
of United about five hundred okay yeah
all right so my six-year-old daughter
says well that's okay that because what
does that stand for whatever we want
that's how that's how sweet oh that just
melts a daddy's heart doesn't it
this is wonderful well I you know what I
would say is the same thing that that we
talk to our kids about the whole time
they were growing up and that that is
just that you know some things you ask
Santa for he does and some things us
Center for he doesn't do and it depends
on you know what kind of stock he has on
the toys and we're not always sure we
can get everything you asked for you
know that right and it's not all and you
know it is kind of based on the Santa's
budgets kind of based on bad and mom's
budget and so it may affect that but hey
you can ask and you know I just want you
to understand that that Santa you know
if you ask for a new jet airplane scent
I wouldn't bring it if you asked for
three new houses if you ask to own a
ritz-carlton hotel Santa wouldn't give
you one because it's just not that's not
gonna happen and so honey you need to
realize that not everything you asked
for Santa gifts I made me remember last
year you asked for a couple things you
didn't get and because they always we
always ask for stuff we can't get from
Santa I did and so you just kind of
manage the expectations that
but also it's okay to say santa's budget
is somewhat based on mom and dad's
budget and we're gonna be looking at
that and Santa will do everything he can
to try to fulfill the wishes but he
can't always do all of them and that's
just true of every household no one has
enough money to answer no no no
household has enough money for Santa to
bring everything everyone wishes for
right right right if you just couch it
in that then it doesn't hit you quite as
much in the face because you're trying
to do a budget and it's just that you
know no matter how much money mom and
dad has Santa is still limited because
he doesn t just some some wishes he just
does not grant and you know it's okay
and just talk about it but I really I
think it it's a bigger deal in your head
than it is the six year olds head
probably yeah cuz you kind of went Oh
wah wah wah as soon as that happen you
know I did kind of melted my heart when
I heard it and I'm just a granddad I
don't have to deal with any of it but I
think you'll be fine and I I definitely
don't think she'll be permanently
scarred this is the Dave Ramsey show